Film producer Jeffrey Katzenberg was responsible
for reviving Walt Disney Studios by producing
some of their biggest hits including The Lion
King, The Little Mermaid, Beauty and the Beast
and Aladdin.
After which he requested a promotion but was
instead abruptly fired.
He swore revenge on the Disney Corporation
and founded DreamWorks Studios.
The reason that artificial banana favouring
tastes so different to actual bananas is because
artificial banana flavourings are based on
a type of banana called Gros Michel bananas,
that were wiped out by a plague in the 1950s.
On an island off the south-west coast of Australia
named “Middle Island” there is a large
lake that is a bright pink bubblegum colour
called Lake Hillier.
A mantis shrimp can swing its claw so fast
that it boils the water around and creates
a flash of light.
Australia has over 10,000 beaches.
You could visit a brand new beach every day
for over 27 years.
To determine if a female is suitable for mating
a male giraffe will approach the female and
rub up against her backside until she pees.
The male then tastes the urine to determine
whether she's in heat or not.
What's even more disturbing is that scientists
thought it necessary to give this bizarre
ritual a name, it's called the “Flehmen
sequence”.
Nintendo was originally a trading card company.
There is an uninhabited island in the Bahamas
known as “Pig Beach” which is populated
entirely by swimming pigs.
A scientist let a computer program a computer
chip using natural selection.
The outcome was an extremely efficient chip,
the inner workings of which were too complex
for a human to understand.
A group of women called “The 9 Nanas”
kept a secret for decades that not even their
husbands knew about.
For 30 years they met at 4am and anonymously
paid bills and bought clothes for people in
need.
Each care package included a homemade pound
cake and a note that read “Somebody loves
you”.
Approximately 1 million Euros are thrown into
Rome's Trevi fountain every year.
The money is used to subsidise a supermarket
for those in need.
As a teenager George R.R.
Martin was the first ever person to buy a
ticket to the first ever comic con, held in
New York City in 1964.
When we breathe through our nose, we inhale
more air from one nostril than the other,
but they swap round every 15 minutes.
The mayor of the Alaskan town of Talkeetna
is a cat called Stubbs.
This faithful ball of fur has been of the
town since 1997.
In 2013 in China, scientists managed to grow
a human tooth using nothing but stem cells
taken from urine.
In 1969 a musician named Jim Sullivan recorded
an album called “U.F.O” which included
unusual lyrics about leaving his family and
being abducted by aliens.
Sullivan disappeared six years later without
a trace.
The only evidence was his abandoned car found
on a desert road.